for the first time Hong Kong's leader
has apologized in person for the chaos
and violence of the past week massive
demonstrations forced her to hold up a
controversial extradition bill
protesters filled it but felt it would
force people in Hong Kong into mainland
China's legal system
ramie Inocencio is in Hong Kong ramie
what did she say good morning Carrie Lam
did offer her most sincere apologies and
said she is sad about the protests and
the violence that's rocked the city in
the past week but questions are rising
about her ability to carry on the issue
of face losing it and being embarrassed
as a major cultural touchstone in China
the fact she showed her face at all
today is surprising but it appears too
little too late for protestors who want
her to step down and withdraw the
controversial extradition bill your
inability to say the word retract to me
at least will continue to sow distrust
in Hong Kong society but you say that
you want another chance here I will not
this is an undertaking
I will not proceed again with this
legislative exercise if these fears and
anxieties could not be adequately
addressed after the press conference
protests organizers said that they do
not accept Carolyn's apology and she
hasn't met any of their demands
Anthony Remy Inocencio in Hong Kong
thanks for me